with two parties at the table here
who are both fully campaigning at the moment
and calls vote for me
because then I will work with rutte
the party of labor
to make pensions even more insecure
for example to Mrs.
Nanica
indeed to say
well more market forces when it comes to living
yes while I really have the idea
that that is not what the Netherlands is at the moment
so you've actually been in this debate here eh
in this whole room
I love to participate in this debate and I eh
behold this
but I think it is ehm
problematic
because I just think really after four cabinets
rutte eh is a week after the presentation
of the report on eh
the hole scandal
uh in groningen
we have seen surcharges scandal
next Tuesday there will be another debate in the second chamber
you won't believe it
but another debate in the second room
because that is still not resolved
and that has everything to do with the dominant vvd
it is not the subject
but u don't understand the flight of yes
twenty-one and the pvda
with the cabinet rutte
no because what we are talking about now
the housing shortage is not a natural phenomenon
this has to do with years of liberal policy
but the problem also just came
discussed around Groningen
for example the surcharges scandal
that is also a result of ideologically political choices
and more market
less people
a government that has become suspicious
relative to their own people
lots of people who experience the government every day
is no longer automatically their ally
and I think that is a very essential problem